kan y saya están comiendo pastel de
calabaza con sus amigos quieren
averiguar cuánto pastel han comido hasta
ahora son siete personas en total y cada
uno se ha comido dos quintas partes del
pastel dos quintos quien dijo que puedes
resolver este problema multiplicando dos
quintos por siete y tiene sentido porque
son siete amigos los que están ahí y
cada uno está comiendo dos quintos por
lo tanto él hizo la multiplicación y
obtuvo 14 35 a vos esto empieza a sonar
raro 1435 a vos veamos esto es lo que él
hizo dos quintos los multiplicó por 7 y
multiplicó 2 por 7 y 5 por 7 es decir
multiplicó tanto numerador como
denominador y de ahí es que obtuvo 14 35
a vos ok
algo aquí no está cuadrando espero que
ustedes ya lo hayan identificado algo
está mal por aquí
y saya dice que 1435 a vos no pueden ser
correctos
claro porque 1435 a vos es menos que un
pastel entero y tiene sentido vamos a
sacar nuestro cuaderno de notas y vamos
a hacer anotaciones para poder resolver
esto nosotros mismos nos están diciendo
que están con su pastel de calabaza no y
ese pastel de calabaza cada quien está
comiendo dos quintos y tenemos un total
de siete amigos
tiene sentido estos dos quintos por 7
esta es la porción que está comiendo
cada uno y estos son los siete amigos
ahora lo que hicieron en el ejercicio
fue multiplicar
dos quintos
por y nos indican que cada uno lo
multiplicaron tanto numerador por 7 y
tanto denominador por 7 de ahí es que
obtuvieron los 14
35 a vos
vamos bien sin embargo esto no es
congruente esto no está bien vamos a ver
por qué nosotros nos podemos dar cuenta
que aquí al multiplicar tanto el
numerador como el denominador realmente
estamos multiplicando por 12 quintos x
7 sobre 7
realmente este 7 sobre 7 es uno lo que
significaría que estamos multiplicando
dos quintos por uno
de ahí es que tengamos entonces dos
quintos realmente lo que hicieron aquí
al multiplicar el numerador y el
denominador por el mismo número fue
hacer una fracción equivalente ustedes
ya conocen estas y al hacer una fracción
equivalente lo único que estamos
diciendo es dos quintos es exactamente
igual es otra representación
de 14 35 a vos
son fracciones equivalentes
si nosotros quisiéramos llegar al
resultado real lo que haríamos es pensar
que dos quintos por siete significa
tener dos quintos siete veces o sumar
dos puntos siete veces por lo que
tendríamos dos quintos más dos quintos
más dos quintos más dos quintos la
cuarta vez más dos quintos ahí ven cómo
el cerebro engaña
dos quintos la cuarta vez más dos
quintos por quinta vez más dos quintos
por sexta vez y este es el dos quintos
por séptima vez uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete si nosotros tenemos una
suma de dos quintos más dos quintos más
doscientos más dos quintos nuestros
quintos más dos quintos más dos quintos
nuestro resultado será cuántos quintos
tenemos dos más dos más dos más dos más
dos más dos más dos
esto es igual a tener 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 2
por 7
quintos y ahora sí tendremos 14 quintos
que hace todo el sentido porque 14 es
más grande que 5 cuántas veces nos cabe
el 5 en 14 pues nos cabe 2 y tendremos
un residuo de cuatro quintos es decir ya
estamos comiendo más que un pastel entre
los siete y eso tiene sentido estamos
comiendo todos pasteles con cuatro
quintos si también no podemos pensar de
alguna otra manera tendremos que dos
quintos x
7 este 7 está sobre 1 recuerda que un
número entero siempre estará con
denominador 1
estaríamos multiplicando entonces dos
quintos por 7 que es un entero lo
colocaremos sobre 1 y con esto podemos
hacer nuestra multiplicación tendremos
entonces 2 por 7
como numerador y 5 por 1 como
denominador con eso hacemos nuestra
multiplicación 2 por 7 14
y en el denominador tendremos 5 por 15
que es exactamente este 14 quintos que
habíamos visto
o dos enteros cuatro quintos vamos
entonces a ver nuestra respuesta
correcta dentro del ejercicio dice cuál
de las siguientes situaciones explica
mejor la situación que no multiplico
correctamente multiplicar dos quintos
por siete es lo mismo que sumar dos
quintos siete veces y es justo lo que
acabamos de hacer se dan cuenta 202
quintos 200 todos los dos quintos siete
veces y llegamos a 14 quintos la
respuesta correcta es 14 quintos o todos
enteros cuatro quintos que justos son
los resultados a los que llegamos parece
que la explicación es la respuesta
correcta sin embargo vamos a leer los
demás para ver que estaba sucediendo y
dónde estaba el truco
que multiplicó correctamente pero olvidó
cancelar los sietes en la fracción no
tendría por qué cancelar los 77 es igual
a 1 y no nos da el resultado no tendría
por qué haber cancelado esos esto es
cuando hacemos fracciones equivalentes
la respuesta correcta sin duda no es be
la explicación se ha dado que quien debe
sumar el pastel de los 7 el debió de
haber sumado siete con dos quintos en
lugar de multiplicar los no claro que
debió de haber multiplicado teníamos la
porción de cada uno por los siete amigos
son multiplicación y finalmente quien
está correcto ellis amigos simplemente
no comieron tanto pastel como creyente
bueno eran siete amigos así es que
ninguna de estas respuestas es la
adecuada sino la explicación vamos a
comprobarlo
y es correcta